Je sais ce qu'était mon père, ce qu'il a fait, je
sais que le roi fou a mérité son
nom,
tuez tous tous les Targaryan, je mets la main
sur tous ceux qui ne sont pas américains, c'est un ennemi,
monsieur, apportez-moi sa tête, votre AR, nous prenons
ce qui est à nous,
le L.  et leurs
aards, tu ne penses pas que je te laisserais épouser
cette bête, n'est-ce pas ?
Je proclame maintenant Cersei de la maison
Lannister protectrice des Sept
Royaumes Lannister targaryan barathan
Stark Ty, ils ne sont que des rayons sur une
roue, celui-ci est au sommet alors  celui-là est
au sommet, et il
tourne, écrasant ceux au sol, la
même chose arrive pour
nous tous, il n'y a qu'une seule guerre qui
compte, la Grande
Guerre, et elle est
ici
[Musique]